so this is a Consolidated web page for
what the research
topics and whether such Fellowship inter
program is all about so when we go down
I think you would have gotten a lot of
introduction about uh how different
students and researchers can make use of
Big Data while performing different
analysis and what do I mean by that
let's go down you will get these
specific advantages of um when you sign
up for the research fellowship program
so you have
curriculum that specifically designed
for the for your research area and for
your research interests and you have
your own self-paced learning and most of
the courses and most of the resources
that we are going to share with you in
the research fellowship program is
asynchronous meaning you will learn at
your pace you will do this at your pace
and then
um we will be there to discuss with you
about your progression about how to
proceed further in the research
fellowship program and you will get
Hands-On with big data as expertly
demonstrated by three students research
topic so all of them
obtain data from publicly available
forum and all of these data are big data
big omics data and they used this big
Comics data to address different parts
of the biological queries and questions
and you will have access to expert
mentors like myself like Dr Mohit and
others so when you start learning you
will get
immediate feedback from us and we are
accessible to you offline and also uh we
we will meet you once or twice during
the week during the scheduled research
fellowship meeting and also if you
request for one-on-one meeting for some
specific cases then we will offer that
also
so when you go down what are the
different areas in which the omics data
and multiomics data in general are being
used to address specific research
questions you have a variety of topics
that uses omics data as of now which
will include genomics data
transcriptomics data epigenomics
metagenomics and these are only few that
we are targeting or that we are actually
focusing on you have furthermore you'll
have proteomics you have metabolomics
and Etc a lot of other omics data types
are coming up in trying to address
different areas of biological research
so and we have actually this site this
web link gives you one of the some of
the major applications of omics data
analysis to different areas of analysis
that is described that is focused so
some of the obvious focuses on
infectious diseases and the pandemic era
that we are currently living is is a
perfect exam sample for what omics data
can achieve in in addressing infectious
diseases case and we all know different
terminologies related to SARS like
variance of concern variance of Interest
how does it spread like um what are the
different lineages right and what are
the mutations that actually characterize
billions of concern these variants of
interest and all of these analysis are
direct results from genomics data and
transcriptomic data analysis so when you
use the whole genome sequence of the
virus and try to compare it with the
other strains and other variants of this
same virus you will get lot of
information and this is just one example
of what you can achieve from from the
from sequencing the whole genome
sequence of the virus and similarly this
can be extended to a transcriptal
landscape analysis which will
characterize how a patient is going to
respond to the onset of the disease or
to some drugs that is going to fight
against is the progression of this
disease and these are just two omics
data types that is trying to provide us
with lot of information in addressing
some of the key questions in infectious
receivers and we can again do this in
meta genomics data analysis and
epigenomics data analysis which are also
extremely important omics data type that
are coming up and I would like to stress
the importance of metagenomics data
analysis where the gut microbiome or the
microbiome
um estimation of the human gut is being
linked to various other disease onsets
like cancer like allergy like even a
neurological disorders and a
pathological state so so that that level
of Association is is been
exploration of that level of Association
is being carried out at various
different labs and and this is one of
the interesting and upcoming omics data
types analysis methods and the questions
that we can answer through uh analyzing
and observing patterns within the
metagenomics data so when you go down we
have lot of project examples on omics
learn which focuses on different omics
data analysis in trying to address key
questions in infectious diseases like
SARS like malarial infection like um the
sf9 cells will actually tell you about
how to uh
identify viral contamination in your
samples and Ebola virus epidemic is an
excellent example of how genomics data
was used to track the progression this
disease progression and spread of Ebola
virus so when you come down the
application of omics data analysis is at
its peak to oncology because of the
requirement and because of how a mixed
data characterizes tumor cancer and
generally the disease progression and
its effect on various types of patients
and various types of
yeah uh on various types of races and
ethnicity so what we get part of the
reason why it is required because of the
existing traditional methods of
identifying characterizing understanding
the disease progression of tumor and
treating the disease tumor disease and
cancer as such is not sufficiently
effective so hence we had to research to
transcriptomics or genomics data
analysis epigenomics data analysis and
Etc so when we have a wealthy of such
information and Big Data it is natural
that methods that are specifically
designed to analyze patterns from these
large quantities of data like Advanced
statistical methods involving artificial
intelligence deep learning machine
learning will come in handy so they are
also at its most useful when you are
trying to use a large volume of data
like transcriptomics data from major
from lot of patients as compiled in a
wonderful public repository like the
cancer genome Atlas or TCG so we also
have a NCA AI database where the SRA
data will provide you lot of genomics
information and genomics data where you
can focus on for example
genome-wide Association studies targeted
loci studies to understand the
specific genes and Driver genes that are
that could be used to an answer and that
could be used to explore the onset this
is progression and the treatment
response of different tumor from
different cases
and there are also efforts in
understanding cancer from integrating
multiple or multi-ohmics uh as such from
maximizing the information and also
integrating the omics data type with a
wealthy of cancer history patient
history database and patient history
data and and the treatment information
data and genetic data genetic history
data generally that most of the
translational approaches will acquire at
the time of diagnosis and we are we can
also use traditional methods like using
structural biology and omics data
in omic data integrated into structural
biology for developing different drug
targets and Drug molecules like
chemoinformatics data to to approach the
translational problems of finding and
identifying targets for for these cancer
research and also finding and
developing treatment strategies for
targeting these specific
targets that we identified from
structural biology efforts
as I mentioned in the previous case
metagenomics has been is one of the
upcoming area that has been linked to
majority of the onset and progression of
disease from various other parts of our
body and this doesn't stop but cancer
and this doesn't stop it uh gut or
chronic diseases development so again to
give you few examples of what are the
different projects that we have in omics
omics learn we have a project that
focuses mainly on the immune response of
the cancer to different uh immune
therapies and we have projects that
deals with mass or a huge volume of data
from the cancer genome Atlas to identify
risk factors that are associated with
the liver cancer and we have
um we have a project that actually tries
to relate omics data with the treatment
response data that is observed from
grafting the tumor into model
environment like Mouse model and like
cell line models Etc and that will
straight away form and that will
straight away lead us from an
understanding oncology through omics
data analysis into
translational aspects of oncology and
precision medicine through the
application of omics data analysis in in
treating cancer so for this specific
for this specific aspect or for this
specific
research research topic then we have one
project where we have multiple other
examples with this specific project
modeling cancer Precision medicine which
I was talking about where the cancer
cells were grown in a Cell line data
cell line in
where they are grown cell line
environment and they were treated with
multitude of different treatments and
their response to different treatments
through uh through the uh
through increase or decrease in the
volume of the tumors are observed and
this response treatment response is
directly linked with multiple omics that
characterizes these tumor cells and by
linking these omics data type and a
treatment response we can identify which
treatments are effective and how we can
use omix data types to effectively or to
accurately identify the effectiveness of
this treatment and this will fall
straight into patient stratification in
terms of which patients or what are the
subset of patients that will respond to
a specific treatment and treatment
stratification in terms of what are the
possible treatment options that I can
suggest to a patient who is likely to
respond to several different treatments
and this doesn't stop but treating hosts
from uh hosts from
um human or from uh majority focus on
Homo sapiens and human this also extends
to agriculture where I believe the
analysis has a lot to offer and the
application has a lot to offer in terms
of understanding for example drought
resistance understanding for example
salinity resistance understanding for
example heat resistance of crops which
naturally have acquire these
characteristics since we are being
since they are being exposed to these
harsh conditions one can one can
characterize the these plants
using again these molecular
characterization methods from omics data
types analysis and then try to apply
whether such uh
whether bringing about such changes in a
different plant can actually result in
developing resistance for Drought
developing salinity in resistance and
also weather can we transfer the ability
of plants to survive in harsh condition
by changing the omics landscape of these
plants so such efforts are actually
actively going on in in agricultural
area and again to stress on the
application of metagenomics data
analysis to a wide variety of biology
and in general people usually take the
soil samples understand the microbiome
population of the soil samples from
different parts right from for example
from from a region which receives very
low rainfall or from a region which
receives very high rainfall so we can
understand what are the different
bacteria fungi and virus that makes you
use of these conditions and effectively
to help the plants grow at its maximum
potential so these are different areas
in agriculture which are actively
upcoming and developing currently and
both in basic mechanistic research and
also in application oriented research in
agriculture in plant biology generally
and Neuroscience is also one of the
field where people have tried to
understand or people have tried to apply
or mixed data analysis from samples from
brain and there is a practical
difficulty in acquiring samples from
brain from for live patients and hence
now there is a lot of effort in trying
to relate to neuroscience and neuro
neurological disorder from samples from
blood or from sample samples from gut
microbiome Etc so an advanced analysis
methods and data science methods are
helping us making these making these
connections that are usually not
observable using traditional analysis
methods and and evaluating them for the
statistical verification or statistical
significance of these connections and
transcriptomics data analysis as I
mentioned is one of the most used omics
data analysis or one of the most applied
Atomic data analysis to variety of in
wide variety of different questions
related to human translational biology
and Neuroscience is not
agnostic to that also so traditionally
people take or people extract samples
once the patients have passed away from
the brain cells and compare it with the
healthy patients who are age matched
gender matched ethnicity matched so that
we are eliminating lot of other
confounding factors in trying to
understand the gene expression landscape
of neurological neuro neurological
disorders compared to healthy patients
so when we extend such analysis to
metabolic disorders like uh like um like
allergic reaction to gluten or like
allergic reaction to some specific uh
metabolism or some uh some people will
have acid reflects so in lot of these uh
these disorders and and and some people
will have difficulty in in
um in filtering salts in Sydney so in
lot of these disorders again Comics data
analysis is actually proving to be very
helpful because
um traditional methods of observing
histological uh data or or bio chemical
assay data is limited in characterizing
the tissue sample tissues and samples in
what they offer and trying to extract
the genes and trying to extract the gene
expression data trying to extract the
DNA from which in the within the cell is
um is actually more helpful in trying to
understand are trying to get a holistic
picture of the samples themselves which
can be uh useful in relating to various
different phenotypical applications and
phenotypical characterizes of these
samples that we have categorized right
we can take uh samples from healthy
patients compare it to samples from who
has developed uh chronic allergy to for
example peanuts and we can understand uh
in what are the major ways the
transcript transcriptomics landscape
differ in between these two samples uh
depending on where the samples are from
samples could be from
um from the skin or from there from the
stomach lining or from the gut
microbiome also so so the various other
omics data types are also explored in
this
um biological approach
so all biology is is not I mean all
biology is not related or limited to
being applied on Earth so upcoming
Research In Space omics where NASA and
other space agencies from all over the
world are heavily
focused and heavily uh investing is the
application of omics data analysis for
understanding the effect of space on on
human body or on model systems so people
have found out effective method to
simulate microgravity on model systems
and microgravity on human cells
themselves so people observe or people
characterize these human cells based on
the omic data analysis or molecular
characterization that will take multiple
different omics data
characterization and then compare it
compare the data compare the data
landscape before and after subjecting
them subjecting the samples or
subjecting the model systems to
microgravity onto a space travel in
terms of uh in terms of astronauts or in
terms of even they took Mouse to
International Space Station once to
perform these analysis so these are the
different fields that biology and
bioinformatics and omics data Big Data
omics data analysis are actually
influencing actively and and very
rapidly right I mean space omics is kind
of a field that nobody would have heard
about three years before and right now
it's actually picking up on even a lot
of upcoming and developing countries are
actually focused on performing or
understanding these uh the effects of
now microgravity and space travel on
astronauts and other
subjects so we have these yeah we have
these different fields that are being
actively explored on by students uh as
they have
as they have
um presented you there research topic of
Interest so it it depends upon what you
want to focus on for example you can
focus on cystic fibrosis you can focus
on SARS CO2 characterization using
different analysis method you can focus
on a non-long long non-coding rnas for
being Targets in leukemia and you can
also focus on different biomark trying
to understand biomarkers or prostate
cancer or cancer types that is not been
studied actively like cervical cancers
prostate cancer and Etc so this doesn't
stop it
um
at the at the uh
uh framework or a different biological
aspects that we are limiting you to you
can also trying to mix match these uh
analysis methods and different
biological questions that you can answer
from these so I encourage you to look or
explore this page and this web page and
web link has lot of information and
links forwarded for YouTube uh
understand the effect of uh research
fellowship program and its reach through
the aspects or through the dimensions or
through the view of students themselves
you can you are free to check uh
different submissions from students and
and uh and the variety of topics that
they were interested in
exploring omics data analysis and their
applications in general so with that
yeah we also have further more links to
some of the major or some of the key
talks from compiled from our previous
webinars and from a symposium that we
successfully conducted at the end of or
the beginning of April rather